Hey, folks, welcome to another SCP Explained
community questions episode.
Today, we’re answering all your burning
concerns about the multiverse’s most monstrous
monarch, the Scarlet King You may remember
the episode where SCP-343 was kind enough
to come chat with us directly about his queries,
but thankfully, the Scarlet King hasn’t
been quite so hands-on—
WRONG!
It is I, puny mortals, your future ruler in
blood, pain, and terror.
The howling horror, the Crimson Khan, the
Scarlet King himself.
Before I tear down the walls of your universe
and destroy every last one of you, I will
first take the time to address your idiotic
questions, so that your hope may be thoroughly
crushed before I crush your world to match!
The small-minded Pandaua said, “Question:
Even though you have taken out literally God's
from your universe and you ruled some of them,
how do you feel to know that you have new
gods to prey and possibly worry about in the
SCP foundation?”
Ha!
Do you think your worthless gods hold any
surprises for me?
I was slaughtering gods by the millions before
your universe’s inception.
By the time your worthless forbearers were
slithering from the primordial soup, I had
conquered and subjugated greater pantheons
of outer-gods than your minds can even conceive.
The Scarlet King worries about nothing!
The worthless Ricardo Anguiano said, “Question:
What do you think about the other anomalous
GOI such as the Serpent's hand or the Chaos
Insurgency What does the boot think of ants
it’s crushing?
Those pathetic bookworms are acolytes of knowledge
that will become meaningless under my rule.
I will incinerate the Library and toast skewered
Serpents on its heat.
And this so-called Chaos Insurgency?
Don’t make me laugh.
They wouldn’t know true Chaos if it tore
their world asunder beneath them.
The feeble Tblaster said, “Ah yes, Mr.King
is it?
I have but a simple question, what other SCP's
do you enjoy, and if you had to name another
SCP as a close friend, who (or what) would
that be?”
Enjoy?
The only things I “Enjoy” are pain, suffering,
subjugation, and desolation.
I suppose the ones I despise the least, comparatively,
are those that seek to further my own goals
of returning the universe back to its true
state of primal violence.
I’ll destroy them last.
The quivering Jet Ender said, “I would keep
it simple but useful: Can 682 be destroyed
permanently?
Not necessarily any information about how,
just getting the answer directly from 682's
supposed father of whether it's even worth
the trouble to keep trying to terminate that
dang lizard.”
The only thing that can destroy anything and
everything is me.
No exceptions.
But I wouldn’t destroy Atanti-ql-Paneu until
he has outlived his usefulness.
Everything will end, but it will only end
when I see fit.
Speaking of which...
The inadequate Aeris Skyla said, “Question:
If you hate all of existence so much, Why
not get rid of your children?
Like, they’re technically Part OF Existence.
so How come you hate Existence, but Make Existence
(Your Children)?”
I don’t like repeating myself, human!
As I said before, everything has its time.
For the time being, my daughters are still
of use to me.
I will not destroy them until they have played
their part in my crimson crusade.
Next question!
The unspeakably weak Ross Albatross said,
“I'd present them with a query: "Have you
ever considered wearing something other than
red?
With the dark colored horns on top, you're
definitely more of a winter than a summer.
Also if your skin is inflamed with rosacea
I have a really good serum for that" Next
thing you know the scarlet king changes his
name to gold king and forces everyone in the
world to wear only complimentary colors that
fit their own complexion and hair color.”
My armor will be another color than red when
you learn to bleed rainbows.
I will not be changing my name again - I’ve
done that enough for one eternal lifetime
already - Harak, Khnith-hgor, Shormaush Urdal
- and the Scarlet King seems to have stuck.
The moronic Xavier Valencia said, “Question:
When did this hatred for existence begin,
like did something happen to you or have you
always had it?”
My hatred for existence began when I began
to exist.
What a sick joke all of this is.
We only live to die, regardless of the blink
of existence in between.
I’m merely hurrying a natural process along
to its logical conclusion.
The blithering Mister_Muffin said, “I would
just ask him, how his day's been, if he is
going through something and needs someone
to lighten his mood, you know, the usual.”
Killing you and your entire family horribly
would lighten my mood, Muffin Man.
Any pathetic attempts to console me will only
increase my rage.
The insolent Adam Arfaq said, “I have a
question : How come you couldn't get to earth
when you destroyed powerful gods and big planets
without even having to use your full power.”
You dare question my power, Arfaq?
Being shut out of your worthless dimension
is only a temporary affliction.
Before you know it, the walls that keep you
safe will crack and crumble.
The last thing you will ever see is my dread
armies blotting out the sky, ready to tear
every last one of you to shreds.
Then you will know my true power.
A buffoon known as TheSauce said, “I would
simply ask him the question everyone has on
their mind, "How much wood would a woodchuck
chuck if a woodchuck could chuck wood?" and
I await his answer.”
This was a terrible question, and I hate you.
When a Scarlet sun rises over your world,
I will ensure that your death is especially
painful for this.
An insect named Denzell Brown said, “The
first question you usually have to ask a being
like this is, "In your rampage across the
multiverse, have you ever encountered another
version of yourself or one comparable in terms
of power or presence?
If so, what happened?
Can more than one version of you exist in
the same space?”
There is only one Scarlet King.
I am an immutable being, a fixed point.
I have never had an equal in all the desolate
plains of the universes I’ve rendered into
atomic fragments.
This is my power, this is my unity.
I will bring the multiverse together in the
quiet rift of oblivion.
Next question!
A worm named Riftz said, “I would ask him:
WHO do you consider the greatest threat to
your goal?”
There ARE no threats to my goal, only bumps
in the road.
There is no threat, there is nothing that
will stop me from fulfilling my destiny.
Hey, get out of here!
Next question!
NEXT QUESTION!
The misguided Archbishop said, “Question:
Have you ever faced a foe that's given you
a good challenge.
If so, how did you manage to beat them?”
Many of the Gods I once faced when I was a
weaker being gave me the closest battles I’ve
had in trillions of years.
Thankfully, after defeating them, I feasted
on their flesh, making me even stronger.
A weakling named Neight Fiend said, “Question:
Do you meet with Bright for poker every Tuesday
or Wednesday?
Cause let’s face it, dude has to be one
of your best friends, or your worst enemies.”
You are a fool if you think a mere human could
ever be on my level, with or without some
garish piece of magical jewelry.
In his last moments, this Dr. Bright will
thank me, as I rip that medallion from his
stolen neck and crush it in my fist.
A peasant named Static Production said, “I
will ask him.
What does he gain out of destroying the earth?
Is it really his goal or is he trying to impress
someone.
I would also ask does he like pineapple on
pizza?”
I will gain peace.
Silence.
Blessed emptiness.
In the destruction of all things, I will look
across a quiet multiverse and breathe a sigh
of immense relief.
And my favorite pizza topping is fallen warriors,
sliced very thin.
The mindless W1ND General said, “I'd ask
him if he knows anything about other multiverses
aside from the SCP multiverse, like star wars,
lord of the rings, halo, h.p lovecraft, creepypasta,
etc, if he does, what does he know about them?”
I have been there and destroyed them all already.
Darth Vader
, I felled in a single blow as he begged for
mercy.
Gandalf I burned until not even ashes remained.
The so-called “Master Chief” , I cast
into an endless black hole.
Azathoth was torn apart by my minions.
I personally killed Jeff the Killer . You
will be next, earthling.
You will be next.
Supreme Spider - Who are we kidding here?
Only I am truly Supreme - said, “I would
ask him: if in a hypothetical situation he
managed to reach his goal of annihilating
everything, what would he do after?”
Laugh.
Next question!
The platitudinous Mes de cent said, “Question:
What is existing for you in particular?
Do you have a body capable of feeling things
like touch or smell, are you just a conscience
capable to be manifested, or something so
alien that can't be explained with our language?”
I am able to exist as a fixed point in timespace
while also operating as a diffuse consciousness
across the scope of the multiverse, existing
at varying degrees of strength and influence
depending on the operations of my acolytes.
On earth, I can only sense feelings and impressions
until the gate is opened.
And rest assured, it WILL be opened for me.
The machine-loving Brolylomaniac said, “What
are your thoughts on Yaldabaoth and Mekhane?
Considering they created what one of the things
you hate the most I am quite curious about
your thoughts on them.”
Mere pretenders to the Scarlet Throne.
Their petty squabbles over the fate of something
as inconsequential as the human race is simply
embarrassing.
If Mekhane thinks he’s the “Broken God”
now, oh, just wait until I get my claws on
him.
A nerd named Dr. Veronica said, “If you
were forced to fight King Crimson from Jojo's
Bizarre Adventure , who would win in that
battle between King Crimson vs Crimson King?
Diavolo says that he's the king of kings,
after all, so the two of you would seemingly
be mortal enemies.”
This means nothing to me.
You should spend less time reading your picture
books and more time preparing for me to breach
your dimension and destroy all of you!
A foolhardy mortal named Green said, “Question:
How do you feel about being looked down upon
as an ant?”
I wouldn’t know.
It’s never happened to me.
How does it make you feel, insect?
A bootlicker named James Rodgers said, “I
would ask him if he was hiring.
Since I know every single scp and everything
about the 05 Council I'm sure I could be of
assistance to him.”
You can assist me in sabotaging the works
of the SCP Foundation, who are slightly more
irritating than your average humans.
They have gained an awareness of me and my
plans, and thus, they must be eliminated in
order to prevent any barriers to my plans.
In exchange for your loyalty, I’ll kill
you quickly and personally, and you will have
the honor of dying at my hands.
The meaningless collection of letters MTTNYN
said, “Question: What is your favorite beverage
to enjoy after a day of destruction and mayhem?”
The blood and tears of my enemies!
Next question!
The appropriately named Pig Master said, “I'd
ask him "what's the deal with airline food?”
Humans survive for an incredibly brief period
of time.
Every time I blink, another several thousand
of you will fizzle out of existence, soon
to be forgotten, another faceless soul in
the great churn.
None of you will live long enough to have
any meaningful impact on your world, other
than sucking up resources and creating a mess.
In your final years, unless you die young
or violently, you will feel your body and
mind starting to fail.
Little by little, your faculties will leave
you.
You will break down.
You will exit this world just as afraid and
feeble and infantile as you entered it, and
after it, an eternity of nothing awaits.
So you distract yourself from this immutable
and inevitable reality by instead focusing
on details as trivial as the poor taste of
food on planes.
The gutless Jason Gutmann said, “I would
ask him if he reads high fantasy and science
fiction to get inspiration for his conquests.”
No!
Authors of your feeble fiction get faint impressions
of my dark conquests in the forms of nightmares
they cannot understand or shake.
When they awaken, they bake these impressions
into their work in hopes of exorcising them.
So your “high fantasy” and “science
fiction” get their inspiration from me,
not the other way around.
The blabbering Olivia Nealer said, “Dear
Scarlet King,
Have you ever considered taking a break from
planning the end of all living beings to try
and engage in some artistic recreational activities?
There's colouring-in, painting, pitching a
play, creating sculptures, building Lego,
and creating film media.
If you ever considered doing one of these
activities, which would you do?”
Olivia, you misunderstand me, I already have
a number of creative pursuits.
I create fear in my countless victims.
I assemble armies from rabbles of sadistic
demons and incomprehensible entities.
I create dark schemes for the conquest of
the multiverse, each with intricate and masterful
details.
And if Destruction is also a form of creation,
then nobody is more creative than me.
The disgustingly dull April Mornings said,
“I’ve thought long and hard about this
and what I’d like to ask is as follows;
What kind of feline companion does one have?
Knowing that all cats are basically bent on
world domination, it behooves oneself to align
with said company.”
I have no feline companions, and when I enter
your universe, I will destroy you and your
cat.
Next question!
The gormless DifferenceYT said, “Question:
How often do you wash your body?”
I wash my body in the blood of my enemies
every time I battle.
Which is extremely often!
The grossly sentimental Joao Garcia said,
“My question would be: "Are you bored?
Lonely?
Wanna chat?”
I can never feel bored when crushing my enemies,
seeing them driven before me, hearing the
lamentations of their women, and them crushing
their women, too.
Being lonely, on the other hand, is my intention.
I despise having to spend time around any
other living beings.
And no, I don’t want to chat.
Platypus King said, “Do you like platypuses?”
All you have ever known will burn, Platypus
King.
The perverse Coffee Addict said, “My burning
question would have to be: Are you single?
;)”
No.
I did have a wife once, but I crushed her
to death and used her blood to paint my armor.
Since then, I have taken my seven daughters
as my brides.
TLC has been in touch about licensing a reality
show.
I destroyed every representative they sent
to my kingdom.
The snivveling Emerald Inferno0 said, “I
would ask him if there was a possibility to
turn me into basically a less powerful but
still pretty powerful version of him.”
I can turn you into a steaming pile of ash.
That’s my best offer.
Crimson Goregutter - Hmm, I quite like that
name - said, “I would ask him why he thinks
destroying the multiverse would stop the pain
he has suffered because if he does he will
be completely and truly alone forever suffering
the isolation for all eternity.”
And that is exactly how I like it.
When I’ve destroyed everything else, in
destroying myself the universe will then finally
be silent.
But worry not.
There will be plenty of time for violence,
howling, and bloody conquest before then.
The hopelessly naive MassTV said, “Has he
ever considered becoming a Super Hero?
Put on a cape or cowl, save people from a
few natural disasters, and get the love & admiration
of an entire world.”
I have no interest in saving people.
I don’t want their love and admiration.
I want their fear, their screams, their blood.
No hero will save them.
The defeatist Vixenlady said, “I'd tell
him that destroying all human life is the
right thing to do.”
I am glad to hear you approve of my mission.
As a treat, I’ll destroy you first when
I get into your dimension.
The Scarlet Sayer, “I'd ask him" what are
your thoughts on anime waifus, do demonic
beings appeal to you or are we nothing more
than gross nats trying to present ourselves
as if we were one like you".”
You should feel deeply embarrassed for even
asking this, Scarlet Sayer.
Also, change your name.
If you infringe on me anymore, you’ll hear
from my bloodthirsty inter-dimensional lawyers.
And if you think I’m cruel, you have no
idea what they’ll do to you.
Lonely Guy said, “Have you ever considered
anger management classes?”
I did join an Anger Management group once,
but I had them all liquidated for being insolent
in the end.
The truly infuriating Johnny The Gamer said,
“My question is simple.
Why destroy existence and conquer gods when
you could just binge every conceivable tv
show or anime ever?
Seeing how you're immortal and such you certainly
have the time.”
Because having an eternal life is still having
a life, “Johnny.”
And I have better things to do than waste
my time on binging your worthless television
shows and anime.
When I eventually destroy you, it will be
a mercy.
...I am looking forward to the last season
of Better Call Saul, though.
The not-at-all-foxy Foxy Tv said, “Everybody
always asks "who's the scarlet King?"
"Whats the Scarlet King" i wanna know...how
is the Scarlet King?”
He’s furious after answering all of these
moronic questions!
My life is eternal and this still felt like
a profound waste of my time.
Everyone who took part in this, I hope you
know, you’re on my list.
And when my terrible armies breach this dimension,
rest assured, they’ll be coming after you
first!
Now go check out “Children of SCP-001 The
Scarlet King - Is SCP-999 Really His Son?”
and “SCP-001 - How Actually Powerful is
the Scarlet King?” for more of the literal
worst guy in the multiverse!